[inaudible]
China has started in what has been the
greatest economic revolution in the
history of mankind.
However,
in spite of this in 2017 both Moody's
and standard and Poor's,
two of the three main rating agencies
reduced the Chinese debt rating.
Brits pause.
The International Monetary Fund itself
has been issuing warnings about this for
months.
Yet the Chinese economy is growing
strongly,
but that does not mean everything is
going well.
In fact,
not at all.
In recent years as we've already
discussed in a video that are linked to
you at the end,
China's economy has seen one parameter
saw exponentially and that's corporate
debt and this isn't small news.
Chinese corporate debt accounts for
almost 170% of China's GDP.
To give you an idea of what this means,
we could say that this 170% GDP level is
one of the highest on the planet and is
a,
for example,
twice that of the United States.
Some of you might be wondering,
well,
if the Chinese economy seems to be doing
so well,
how did its companies accumulate such a
huge debt?
Well,
the truth is that in recent years,
Chinese companies have gone on a sort of
spending spree.
You all over the world,
they've bought everything foreign
companies,
ports,
airports,
minds,
railways,
even soccer teams,
[inaudible]
knees invasion seemed unstoppable.
And then that's precisely what caused to
so many countries do develop an
aggressive discourse against this kind
of occupation.
And not only that,
as the Chinese have begun investing in
the poorest countries in Africa,
many analysts,
journalists and activists have accused
Beijing of practicing this sort of
colonialism.
Do
beware,
because this phenomenon is really quite
widespread.
Companies,
investors,
entrepreneurs,
government institutions,
it does not matter.
In recent years,
the obsession to get money out of China
has been shared practically the only
every person in the Chinese economy now.
So all these,
some of the might now be thinking,
well,
Chinese people buying all kinds of
things are important over the world.
People in Beijing,
they've got to be rubbing their hands
together.
Right?
Well,
the truth is that no,
actually nothing could be further from
the truth.
In fact,
throughout the last year,
Xi Jinping's government has launched
many measures to stop this process.
Oh,
well,
I'm just a moment.
And the Beijing government actually
wants to stop this Chinese purchase
wave.
I mean,
protecting,
they're wanting to take over the world.
Well,
it's not that they don't want to,
but they certainly do have their reasons
for this.
So listen up.
Yeah.
Other face of Chinese investment we
mentioned we want to invest abroad.
As you can imagine,
we can do it in many different ways.
For example,
we can buy debt from a foreign
government,
from a foreign company,
from a foreign bank.
We can also buy shares in another
country,
stock markets,
but we can also carry out what is known
as foreign direct investment that is by
a local company,
opened a store,
a factory,
oh workshop,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
In other words,
invest in a real asset in field.
Oh,
we gotta sneak a direct foreign
investment implies a greater degree of
complexity,
certainly greater risk,
which is why it's expected to generate
greater profitability.
Of course,
if it wants,
there would be no incentive to implement
them.
After all,
it's infinitely easier to buy financial
assets while sitting in front of a
computer at the office,
or even just in your pajamas hunting
them.
Well,
the fact is that paradoxically is this
type of investment has grown in recent
years.
It's profitability has actually
plummeted according to China's stinked
currency administration.
The rate of return,
this type of investments profitability
dropped to barely 0.4% in 2016 oh.
Despite the fact that almost every stock
market was skyrocketing.
Therefore,
in spite of the colonial isn't
accusations.
The truth is that many of the Chinese
investment projects off working so
badly,
but that more of a headache than a
business of the century.
No.
Before you might be thinking,
well,
hold off a minute,
Simon,
I mean,
what exactly is the problem here?
Is it simply that that dress making too
little money?
Well,
according to what we learned about
corporate desk,
yeah,
it is a large part of this huge
international expansion was financed
with debt data.
That,
of course must be repaid with interest.
And if the investments fail or don't
generate the expected returns,
it could create a huge solvency problem,
which would obviously seriously affect
the Chinese financial system,
which belongs fundamentally to the
government.
Take for example,
v Signer Hydro and China Railway
Engineering Corporation,
case to engineering and construction
companies owned by the Chinese
government.
You see,
in 2007 they reached a huge agreements
with the Congolese government in
exchange for a concession to exploit
copper.
Are they committed to investing $9
billion in the African country,
3 billion in the mine,
and 6 billion in infrastructure to
government owned companies that had
nothing to do with mining and we're
entirely financed by a Chinese
government owned.
Thank you.
These
Chinese companies have already invested
more than $2 billion and so far
everything's been a problem.
The price of copper fell.
The reserves went as big as expected.
The logistical costs were really high
because they hadn't even guaranteed that
power supply.
And of course all of this man's many
costs and many,
many delays.
Only nine years later in 2016 were they
able to start extracting copper in much
lower quantities and then extract it?
So whatever the future holds.
The reality is that during the last
decades,
this agreements was a big headache,
is a great sauce of losses.
And don't think that this project was an
exception.
The truth is that in recent years,
Chinese companies government owns,
and it's private companies alike,
I've gotten into serious debt,
buying all kinds of assets without
caring about the price.
That is not all.
In addition,
all these investments,
I mean capital leaving the country at
such a high rate,
the between 2011 and the beginning of
2017 Chinese currency reserves plummeted
by $1 trillion.
And that my friends is a lot of money.
And it's something that goes in the
opposite direction of what Beijing one
switch in recent years trying to
strengthen the yuan.
So now we come to the question of why
are Chinese investors suit eager to get
money out of the country?
Why do they seem so surprisingly bad
when it comes to investing abroad?
Well,
listen up.
Yep.
Bad incentive.
Sorry.
So the fact that Chinese investors seems
so in competent when it comes to
investing abroad is a matter of
incentives and to be a rocker a,
see the main priority for the Chinese
who managed to make money is to transfer
part of birth,
their assets abroad.
So why is this?
Well,
it's fundamentally a matter of legal.
Hello
me to explain.
As you know,
China is a dictatorship and that means
that if tomorrow you have a problem with
the political power,
your money could just disappear.
And not only that,
as in any dictatorship,
there are many restrictions because if
things go wrong,
what could be better?
And having part of your patron any
protected in other countries,
it seems pretty sensible rights.
I think most people would do it.
I mean,
yeah.
Well that's
one of the explanations for why so many
Chinese businessmen wanted to invest
their money as quickly as possible,
even if it meant paying a premium may
sort of surcharge.
But that isn't the only reason.
Additionally,
in recent years since 2008 the Chinese
government promoted easy and cheap
credit has a mechanism to boost the
economy and of course when you can get
into death under such favorable
conditions,
you wouldn't be as demanding when
selecting which projects to invest in.
Yes,
this is one of the big problems with
expansive monetary policies.
They encourage bad investments that
later aren't really difficult to pay
off,
but hold on a moment.
The entity is most responsible for the
huge slab of corporate dads to this.
We've talked about have not been private
companies.
That's actually one's owned by the
state.
And this though surprising also has a
lot to do with incentives.
See investing outside of the country in
large amounts men's cause that managers
could puff up their chests before the
Beijing government view to the growth
that that companies had achieved.
On the other hand,
it meant many of these managers cause
can move on.
So you ran another country and charged a
lot of money.
Let's say that their interests are
different from those of their company.
Of course if business was done in
countries as complicated as Africa,
it was also easier to take a slice gets
a commission,
shall we say.
In addition,
Chinese state owned companies have huge
bureaucratic structures which makes
decision making and adapting to any
changes that may occur very,
very slow.
Yup.
State owned companies tends to be much
more inefficient.
While that's what's CG Peng wants to
face up to while trying to consolidate
his power.
Dangerous Game [inaudible] this huge
shopping mal strum,
which is often done without too much
thought also happens in Japan in the
1980s that is before the Greek crisis of
the early nineties and in Beijing.
They're terrified that something similar
will happen to them.
So what do you think they did well,
the introduced a lot of restrictions on
foreign investments in such a way that
now the Chinese government can veto
corporate operations abroad for Chinese
companies even if they are carried out
by private companies.
Yes,
this has a double intention because in
addition to cooling the foreign
investment process,
it also strongly reinforces Xi Jinping's
political power.
Let's see that with this excuse the
Chinese government has taken and
enormous mechanism out of its sleeve to
reward friends and to punish the less
loyal.
In addition with the excuse of
increasing control,
Beijing is also promoting the merging of
government owned companies,
which until now works autonomously to
create huge corporations and this gives
Beijing even more power.
Of course,
all these actions can weigh on the
growth of Chinese companies.
They can decrease competition and
increase the bureaucracy in efficiency
with which the Chinese public sector
operates.
But yes,
Xi Jingping we'll get even more power.
China has many strengths but this is one
of its great weaknesses.
Even so Chinese savings are so high that
it seems difficult to reproduce a
financial crisis like the one the Japan
experienced,
but the risk certainly does exist.
That was your turn.
Do you think that Xi Jinping's ambitions
well ends up hurting China?
Well,
leave you all answer in the comment
section below as well as in this survey.
I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos.
These also check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine.
Also,
this channel is possible because of our
Patriot ans the Patriots on that
platform.
Please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next year.